all right so let's talk about the
absolute best type of protein that you
can eat
well it's the egg and we're going to
talk about why I mean even some of the
pharmaceutical companies right now are
looking at ways of extracting certain
proteins from eggs and using them in
Pharmaceuticals because of the wide
spectrum of benefits they isolated over
1500 different unique proteins in eggs
and these proteins have a wide variety
of functions including support of your
immune system
anti-microbial anti-cancer
anti-inflammatory there's a whole list
of benefits so let's Dive Right In so
what is an egg well you have the yellow
part of an egg which is a yolk and you
have the white part of the egg and
collectively we call that the egg even
though the egg is really the yolk the
white part of the egg is not the egg
it's the food for the actual egg the
yolk and so what's so special about the
egg it's very different in other sources
of protein most other sources of protein
are must tissue okay well an egg is an
embryo and the quality of nutrition in
eggs is just off the charts it has a
higher quality amino acids than any
other protein out there except breast
milk and it has probably one of the most
diverse uh bands of nutrients okay of
any other proteins as well as the
bioavailability of nutrients it has
pretty much all of the fat soluble
vitamins it is virtually all
water-soluble vitamins as well except
vitamin C so it's a quality source of
protein of course if you're not
consuming conventional eggs the best
type of eggs you should get would be
pasta raised organic eggs now if you can
actually raise your own chickens get
your own eggs that would be the best
thing that's what I'm doing or get eggs
from the farmer's market because
depending on the diet of the chicken
there is huge variances of nutrients if
the diet of the chicken is just right
you can get up to 20 times more vitamin
E up to five times as much vitamin D up
to 10 times the vitamin A I'm talking
about retinol the bioactive form of
vitamin A and even up to six times the
selenium now unfortunately in 1968 the
egg has gotten a bad wrap due to this
whole cholesterol issue and then it took
roughly about 50 years to repair that
bad reputation because in 2015 finally
after all this time they dropped this
dietary cholesterol and egg restriction
we can now go back to eating eggs of
course after all this bad information
about eggs has been ingrained in us for
so many years now there's two main
viewpoints on cholesterol cholesterol
itself in the diet increases the
cholesterol in your blood which then
clogs your arteries that's one Theory
and the second theory is that the
cholesterol builds up
as a result of or a consequence of
having inflammation or damage in the
inside of the arteries because
cholesterol is part of the Band-Aid that
heals the inside of the arteries and
based on a lot of quality research the
second theory is more probable so let's
go through some of the nitty-gritty
um protein okay as far as protein goes a
lot of different sources of protein
don't end up as body tissue protein a
good amount of that is wasted either as
nitrogen waste or it is turned into
glucose but roughly about 49 of eggs is
converted to body tissue which is pretty
much the highest efficiency that you're
going to get from all the different
types of protein excluding breast milk
now as far as the nutrients go the egg
has every single fat soluble vitamin
vitamin A d e k vitamin K1 and vitamin
K2 which is an amazing vitamin that
helps you extract calcium out of the
soft tissues so these fat soluble
vitamins are essential in brain health
in Hormone Health in your eyes and so
most of the fat soluble vitamins are in
the yolk part but the yolk also contains
all of your B vitamin B1 B2 B3 B5 B6
biotin B12 and even the white part of
the egg is loaded with B vitamins as
well the yolk also contains some really
rich minerals a lot of trace minerals as
well as other minerals like it has
magnesium potassium it has phosphorus
calcium it has iodine it has selenium
zinc copper so it's a really good source
of minerals eggs are a good source of
omega-3 fatty acids which are
anti-inflammatory the egg yolk is a
really good source of choline
choline is the antidote to cholesterol
it helps break down cholesterol it helps
the brain work it helps all the
neurotransmitters out of all the foods
liver is the highest in choline egg yolk
is the second now if I was going to ask
you what has more protein the egg white
or the yolk you probably say the egg
white right well actually that's not
true the egg yolk has 15 protein and the
egg white only has 11 protein which is
actually quite interesting because you
have people that think they're getting
more protein from the egg whites when
they're not all right what else does the
egg yolk have the egg yolk has
carotenoids what are carotenoids well
carotenoids are are compounds that give
you additional
health benefits like lutein and
zeaxanthin which both are crucial for
preventing macular degeneration and
supporting the eye especially if you're
a diabetic they are now finding that
eggs have a wide range of antimicrobial
properties especially for your gut eggs
are a great source of antioxidants eggs
have certain proteins that are
anti-inflammatory and like I said before
eggs have properties that help counter
cancer in tumors eggs also have
immunoregulatory properties that support
things like IBS colitis
other inflammatory conditions of the gut
and if you think about colostrum is in
milk and that supports the immune system
of a growing calf and also if it's
breast milk of a growing baby well eggs
also has its own colostrum for a growing
chick and so there is a type of
classroom in egg that can actually
benefit your immune system as well
there's even some interesting proteins
in eggs that help lower your blood
pressure so how many eggs should you
consume in a day well it really depends
on your size and your desire for eating
eggs I consume roughly at least four
sometimes eight eggs every single day
and because sometimes we'll have eggs as
my first meal as well as my second meal
simply because we have access to a very
high quality egg Source because we
actually have our own chickens and those
chickens are producing a lot of eggs
we're getting like probably 15 to 16
eggs every single day so I'm trying to
figure out what to do with these eggs
but if you have any hesitation about
eggs thinking that it's bad for your
cholesterol I created this video for you
to watch right here check it out